on en parlait en début d'émission samedi
prochain le 10 juin c'est la nuit du
handicap partout en France et parmi les
35 communes qui participent Versailles
au programme des ateliers des jeux ou
encore du sport de 15h30 à 22h dans les
jardins de la mairie de Versailles pour
en parler avec nous Marion trop de Salt
responsable des bénévoles pour
l'association La Nuit du handicap à
Versailles bonsoir et vous êtes
accompagné de Xavier de Senneville
l'organisateur de cet événement à
Versailles bonsoir alors première
question pourquoi c'est important pour
vous pour cette sixième édition de
revenir et de recréer un événement la
nuit du handicap à Versailles
bien parce qu'on on est là dans la
continuité ça fait 6 ans qu'on organise
ce magnifique événement le covid n'a pas
eu raison de nous puisqu'on a réussi à
nouveau à relancer ce spectacle et cette
animation dès 2021 et donc vous l'avez
dit 36 villes aujourd'hui dans en France
entière et donc les Yvelines il y en a
36 apparemment on est la 36e
et donc Versailles les Yvelines
voulaient voler s'associer et on a été
une des premières villes aussi à
animer à faire que cette cette fête soit
une véritable rencontre entre les
personnes porteuses handicap et le grand
public alors quels sont les personnes en
situation de handicap qui sont concernés
par cet événement toute j'imagine tous
les handicaps en fait tout est toutes
les toutes les personnes surtout qui
veulent venir faire la fête parce que
c'est avant tout un une journée de
festive une journée joyeuse et que
chacun puisse montrer ses talents et
c'est vraiment l'objet de notre de notre
rendez-vous c'est faire que la rencontre
ait lieu entre les personnes qui ont
entre toutes les personnes qui ont des
Talents qu'elles soient handicapées ou
non il y aura de la danse de la musique
du sport quels seront les activités que
vous allez proposer samedi alors du coup
on fait venir des personnes artistes qui
seront sur scène et qui présenteront il
y aura du théâtre de l'handicabarret
jouer par des jeunes autistes d'accord
il y a beaucoup d'activités comme ça qui
vont sur scène qui vont se succéder et
puis il y a des activités sur la dans
les jardins de la mairie de Versailles
où on peut essayer le handy
les gelettes il y a on fait venir le du
Cécifoot et il y a aussi de la cécie
pétanque et en fait tout ça c'est créer
une activité pour pour créer la
rencontre et le but aussi c'est de se
mettre dans la peau d'une personne en
situation de handicap et montrer que
tout le monde peut faire du sport
finalement j'imagine oui c'est ça c'est
se rendre compte des difficultés qu'on
peut avoir faire ouvrir les yeux le cœur
et l'esprit aux personnes et pour pour
comprendre les difficultés des personnes
handicapées que le handicap soit visible
ou invisible et pourquoi pas dans la rue
enfin allaitendre la main à une personne
connaissant un peu les difficultés
qu'elle peut avoir c'est plus facile de
briser les clichés les préjugés qu'on
peut avoir sur sur l'handicap et les
personnes en situation d'handicap par ce
biais là le sport la musique la danse
bah oui tout à fait parce que tout le
monde peut faire du sport en fait qu'on
soit handicapé ou pas et d'ailleurs ils
sont très forts parce que faire du
basket ou du rugby en fauteuil roulant
du volet assis c'est assez sportif et
nous quand on s'y essaye et ben on se
fait battre à pas de couture et voilà et
c'est chouette de voir ça ça
on est plein d'humilité de enfin c'est
vraiment une journée enfin des partages
qu'on fait dans la joie et les
rencontres sont vraiment belles
je veux bien ajouter aussi que c'est
aussi une avant tout c'est la fête la
rencontre est une fête donc on est là
pour s'amuser et donc par des activités
ou autre mais il va y avoir un spectre
des spectacles mais il va y avoir aussi
un cabaret il va y avoir une guinguette
donc chaque année pendant 5 ans 100% de
sourire à la fin de cette journée et ça
c'est une voilà c'était la joie il a
réussi pour tout le monde alors
justement quel est votre meilleur
souvenir finalement de cette journée de
cette nuit du handicap parce que vous en
avez organisé plusieurs précédemment
est-ce que vous avez un meilleur
souvenir
alors déjà on a un livre d'or on aurait
dû venir avec pour vous dire tout ce
qu'on a recueilli comme comme sensation
comme expression de cette joie qui anime
tout un chacun et
puis oui dans un souvenir extraordinaire
c'est un flash Bob qu'on a organisé et
qu'on a commencé à avec ceux qui avaient
répété à 5 10 15 20 personnes on a fini
avec plusieurs centaines de gens qui
étaient là comme ils étaient avec quoi
ils sont venus et ça c'était à une
c'était merveilleux il y aura aussi un
flash-bob cette année vous réitérer
assurance succès Marion trop de sol
votre meilleur souvenir oui alors moi je
parlerai de de d'une rencontre en fait
cette nuit de handicap elle est aussi là
pour aller vers les personnes touchées
par le handicap les familles qui sont
touchées par le handicap et de se rendre
compte que des personnes sont très
seules et finalement qui qui reviennent
avec joie l'année précédente et l'année
suivante pardon et que vraiment c'est
touchant et c'est fait pour ça
rompre la solitude aussi des personnes
l'année dernière vous aviez accueilli
1300 personnes environ il me semble
cette année vous attendez combien de
personnes et est-ce que la nuit du
handicap ça devient un rendez-vous à
Versailles
alors on est oui la nuit du handicap à
Versailles ça y est c'est inscrit au
programme chaque année
et
et oui enfin c'est
ça devient un rendez-vous et est-ce que
vous attendez combien de personnes vous
attendez finalement cette année on était
oui à 1300 l'année dernière et là on a
préparé 1800 tickets il faut être parce
qu'on essaie de compter chaque année
voilà et on espère toujours être plus
nombreux et alors comment ça se passe
concrètement les infos pratiques si on
veut venir si on veut y participer on
vient et ensuite programme
ça démarrera 15h30 et on finit par un
bal jusqu'à 22h et le programme français
est affiché il est aussi dans beaucoup
de médias de réseaux sociaux etc et donc
voilà on a une programmation certes
beaucoup moins ambitieuse que vous
monsieur mais on a quand même du théâtre
mais on a quand même de la musique on a
quand même des voilà de d'autres
activités mais 100% joyeuse déjà réunir
de la danse de la musique et du sport
sur une même journée et c'est déjà un
beau challenge
bien merci beaucoup en tout cas Marion
trop de Sault et Xavier de Senneville
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
je le rappelle la nuit de handicap ce
sera ce samedi 10 juin dans les jardins
de la mairie de Versailles